what's going on people in this video
we're about to break down episode 18 of
attack on titan season 4 in which the
beast titan finally joined the battle
against mali the title of this new
episode was sneak attack and today i'll
be talking about everything i felt
needed explaining including why the
scouts are helping the aegirus the
significance of gabby ripping falco's
armband and the problem with yell in his
face
to get straight into it the episode
begins where we left off last week with
armin theorizing that maybe aaron
doesn't believe in zeke's euthanization
plan and that he's just using his
brother so he can protect the island
with the rumbling if that was the case
it would give the scouts a solid reason
to go out and help him but with the
limited information they have right now
they can't be 100 sure that aaron is on
their side despite this lack of
certainty in the end they do decide to
take a chance and save him because they
each have their own reasons for not
wanting him to die
in john's case a funny detail was that
he revealed he was actually jealous of
aaron at one point and to be honest this
isn't something he hid very well whether
it was aaron's close relationship with
mikasa or him being a titan shifter or
the fact that his goals were more noble
at least in the beginning there was
always one reason or another for jon to
get jealous so you can begin to
understand why they used to fight so
often
anyway as they go to free the remaining
soldiers and get suited up mikasa
wonders why aaron would try to push them
away if his true intention is to betray
zeke after all if he's really on their
side then surely he wouldn't need to be
this aggressive if he was only
pretending and at this point in the
episode armin has a flashback to three
years ago back then when they first made
it to the ocean aaron asked if they'd be
free if they killed all their enemies
across the sea and i guess the key
phrase to highlight here is all their
enemies the reason armin thinks of this
flashback is because if aaron seriously
wanted to kill everyone outside the
island then that would explain why he'd
want to have distance between him and
his childhood friends an act of violence
on this scale is something that's never
been done in human history so by aaron
pushing them away neither armin or
mikasa would bear any of the
responsibility or the guilt for his
actions that being said armin basically
changes the subject to mucus's headaches
earlier in the episode she mentioned how
these headaches were evidence of her
lacking free will since erin claimed
acumens only get these when their true
self is trying to resist their
programming his point was that mikasa
only wants to protect him because her
dna is forcing her to but armin argues
that aaron was lying and used his
pre-existing knowledge about the
headaches to make this lysy more legit
the two of them then agree to simply ask
him about it once everything is over and
the scene cuts to above ground where the
man himself is quite literally fighting
for his life having already been shot in
the head by mcgath and stabbed through
the shoulder with a spike of his own
hardening the attack titan still
relentlessly tries to win the fight he
gets the armor titan to back off by
triggering another set of spikes out the
ground and ryan himself even starts to
wonder what aaron is fighting for and
why he keeps on struggling the answer to
that question is that besides having an
unusual level of willpower aaron knows
that once he horizon shiganchena like
they agreed the simple act of them
making contact would win the battle
that's why it was smart of him to stay
in fight instead of trying to escape
like elena wanted him to since the odds
would instantly shift in their favor
once his brother gets there we then get
this hilarious sequence of galileo
pouncing onto aaron only to get slapped
halfway across the gachana and if i was
porco i'd just give it up at this point
because when it comes to this match up
he can't ever seem to deal the finishing
blow
luckily for the warriors reiner catches
the attack titan off guard only a few
seconds later and as he pins aaron down
he thinks to himself how he just wants
this to be done
from the start of the season rhino has
had the aura of someone who is mentally
exhausted by the constant fighting and
suffering that he's been through which
is why he can't understand why aaron
continues to fight despite all the odds
being against him the attack titan
demonstrates his persistence again by
grabbing the warrior's upper draw and
just using brute force to try and rip it
off and considering he's the one being
pinned down this is a pretty impressive
feat of strength the scream he let out
while doing it was so loud that it
almost acted like an sos signal since
zeke and the remaining jaegers had just
made it back to the wall the beast tyson
then reintroduces himself by launching a
pitching assault directly at reiner's
head and amazingly this isn't even the
first time he's wrecked the armored
titan in shiganjina
following that he takes out chunks of
hardening from the wall and sends it
flying towards mali's airships and the
destruction of these ships is a big deal
because it means the forces on the
ground have one less thing to worry
about what was really impressive about
this moment though was that after doing
two pitching assaults in a row zeke was
already geared up to do a third which he
directed at the car titan
in this scene the most important thing
for the beast was that he launched this
shot before magath had a chance to fire
the anti-titan cannon otherwise this
fight might have been over there and
then
as you can tell mcgath was desperate to
punish zeke for betraying mali and i
think a lot of his resentment comes from
the fact that as the former head of the
warrior unit he never once realized that
zeke was secretly working against them
it is true to say that he did consider
zeke to be a mysterious person but still
i imagine it hurts him to know that this
betrayal happened from someone that he
allowed to become a warrior
anyhow with the card titan hanging off
the wall and the aegis approaching pique
had no other option but to run it's
actually implied that they chased her
around nearly the whole length of
shiganjina since here she was on zeke's
left side but by the end of the episode
she was on his right side meaning she
likely would have gone the long way
around
a weekend aaron then starts limping
towards his brother so they can make
contact while on the ground gabby and
cole decide to go and find falco
although colt didn't want her to come
gabby was on a mission to repay her
fellow warrior candidate since the only
reason falco is in a cell with zeke's
spinal fluid inside him is because he
kept saving her on different occasions
inside the cell he has a conversation
with nile who's another person that's
been contaminated and in this moment it
seemed like he accepted he's not going
to see his family again
unlike irvin who is willing to abandon
this idea of having a family to pursue
his dream nile always considered his
wife and daughters to be the most
important thing hence why he took that
stand against the nobles in season 3.
for that reason it is especially
heartbreaking that he's been put in the
situation but later in the episode nile
at least did what he could to reunite
falco with his family
as the scouts and the aegis free more
and more prisoners pixies begins to
organize them and he decides that those
without black armbands will get what's
left of the odm gear while those with
the armbands will fight on the front
lines this was the most logical way of
doing things considering that you know i
mean people with the armbands could be
titanized by zika any time so it'd be a
waste of equipment to give them odm gear
only for them to then become pure titans
as a side note instructor shard has made
his first appearance since flock had him
beaten up by the cadets but due to his
injuries that may or may not actually be
bear related he told connie to go on
without him in the changing room mikasa
gets suited up for battle with her
number one fan louise and as she
mentions they are now fighting for
similar goals again the last time these
two interacted louise was in a cell
after helping flock and the yeagaris to
leak information but since then the
political situation has obviously
flipped with the old leaders of the
island either being dead or not doing so
great
an interesting detail is that mikasa
chose to leave her scarf behind and this
could mean a couple of things for
example it could be because she's still
questioning whether her attachment to
aaron is off her own free will or
perhaps she just left it because she's
still seriously hurt by him saying he
hated her either way it's clear that
regardless of whether aaron was telling
the truth about these things he still
succeeded in creating distance between
them by making mikasa doubt her own
feelings
on the outside yelena is genuinely the
happiest person on the island because as
far as she's concerned this is about to
be the moment when the euthanization
plan becomes a reality the scouts
themselves then come out at just the
right time to get a good view of
everything and jon starts to question
what happened to levi and hanji he knew
the captain would have never let zeke go
of his own free will and yelena
correctly assumes that the beast titan
defeated him although to be fair he was
super lucky not to have died in the
process
now in spite of this armin tries to
motivate everyone to help the yeager
brothers make contact since he believes
more than anyone else that aaron is
secretly on their side in armin's head
he thinks that eren will trigger a small
rumbling using the titans in shiganjina
whereas obviously yana believes that the
first thing aaron will do is remove the
ability of aldians to reproduce although
they do think different things will
happen they do essentially still have
the same goal which is to reunite aaron
and zeke hence why armin wants to
actively help the aegirus we then get
this moment from jonada where she pulls
one of the weirdest faces we've seen
from either a titan or a human in fact
it was so terrifying that mikasa
actually went to grab her sword in terms
of the reason behind why she pulled his
face i mean there are two reasons here
firstly there's the real life reason
which is that i kind of think this
moment was meant to be a jumpscare kind
of thing and the second reason is that
yelena was trying to figure out army's
true intentions
prior to this armin cried when she told
him about the euthanization plan and
although he tried to pretend like he was
in favor of it in his own mind he
clearly thought that aaron would never
go along with it therefore it's possible
that yelena wasn't really sure if she
believed that he was being genuine but
now having stared deep into his soul she
has faith that he is really on her side
moving down to ground level colt and
gabby were on the search for falco and
the eldest warrior candidate was armed
with both a regular rifle and an
anti-titan rifle this rifle is good for
killing pure titans if you can get a
direct hit on the nape but when it comes
to shifters it's highly unlikely to do
any damage evidenced by this brief
exchange earlier in the episode
as they continue to search the streets
colts and falco then catch a glimpse of
each other and like i mentioned earlier
nile willingly reunites the two brothers
what was interesting about this
interaction was that colt was bracing
himself to shoot now because he didn't
really have a choice but it was gabby
who instinctively held him back if this
had happened a month ago i mean she
probably would have grabbed the gun and
taken the shot herself so this moment
here really puts into perspective how
much she's changed her experience with
the braz family caused her to realize
that eldians here weren't the island
devil she was told about because they
still showed her compassion even after
finding out she killed sasha this
gradually led to gabby feeling guilt
about sasha's death for the first time
and in this episode the same thing
happens again when she overhears the
brows family talking it wasn't long
until gabby then began confessing
everything she'd realized but she did
acknowledge that falcon rhino already
knew this stuff in the spirit of
confessing things falco himself then
admitted his responsibility in helping
aaron to orchestrate the attack on
liberio but the real plot to us here is
that he finally revealed his true
feelings about gabby his motivation to
become a warrior and inherit the armored
titan was always rooted in his desire
for gaby to have a long life which is
similar to how aaron and marcel did what
they could to stop people they loved
from becoming titan shifters
in any case falco made these confessions
since he wanted to get it out in the
open before he's titanized which leads
to gabby aggressively ripping off the
armband the significance of her doing
this goes way beyond the fact that she
wants to save him and i'll explain why
back in liberia she talked about how
everything she'd worked for was to prove
that aliens from mali were good people
unlike the devils on parodies and her
aim was to create a world where they
could be proud to wear these armbands
since then her worldview has completely
changed and based on what she knows now
it's clear that these bits of claws
shouldn't define a person yelena even
admitted that the black armbands were an
idea inspired by mali so gabby ripping
it off in this way is basically a symbol
of her overcoming the prejudice she used
to have
anyway the warrior candidates head off
to find zeke since colt believes his
former mentor might choose not to scream
if he realizes that falco drank the
spinal fluid meanwhile eren continues to
drag himself towards his brother as the
beast provides support with galliard
getting taken out for the 100th time
this season
to zeke's right hand side the remains of
the kart titan made it seem like pique
was killed by flock and the igress and
there's a good reason why he looks so
upset in this moment
it's worth remembering that these two
spent five years together in mali while
the other warriors were on parodies so
they do have a strong history that's not
been explored that much however in this
situation pique's supposed death was a
fake out that enabled molly to have this
sneak attack cause like any other
shifter if the user fully exits the body
then the titan will start to disappear
by doing this simple trick pig managed
to fool everyone into thinking she'd
been defeated giving them one chance to
catch the beast titan by surprise a plan
like this only works because it means
that everyone else puts their guard down
and mcgath took advantage by firing the
cannon through zeke's back
if we pause on this screenshot you can
see he took a massive chunk from around
the neck area but this sneak attack
wasn't accurate enough to kill the man
inside regardless what this has done is
create a situation where aaron is no
longer protected by the pitching assault
meaning in the next episode reiner may
possibly have a clearer path to stopping
him unfortunately for falco with the
yeager brothers now being in this tricky
position the best way physique to defend
them is with an army of pure titans
that's why as the episode ends magat's
main priority is to quickly finish him
off with a second shot since if he
summons the horde of titans the entire
battle will change in a second
anyway people that was my breakdown for
episode 18 of attack on titan season 4
and if you liked it then i'd appreciate
if you hit that sub button and let me
know your thoughts down below until the
next one peace out